[Musique]
du haut de ses 232 mètres d'altitude le
mont royal domine la métropole depuis
presque quatre cents ans mais peut-être
plus pour très longtemps l'ex maire
denis coderre qui tente un retour en
politique aimerait permettre l'érection
de taux encore plus haute que la
montagne ce qui est interdit depuis
l'adoption du premier plan d'urbanisme
de la ville de montréal en 1992
[Musique]
vos protégés de montréal comme ils ont
toujours été faits comme je le défends
les pommes de toute façon mais la
densité c'est sérieux il faut sortir du
dogmatisme continue il faut arrêter
d'avoir des phrases toutes faites il
faut avoir une vraie un vrai débat sur
l'enjeu
le centre ville compte actuellement deux
gratte-ciel de 200 m le 1000 de la
gauchetière officiellement la plus
grande tour de montréal et 2250 rené
lévesque c'est au pied de cet édifice
que nous attend jean marc fournier cet
ancien ministre défend aujourd'hui les
intérêts des promoteurs qui plaident eux
aussi pour une densification accrue
d'abord il faut savoir quelle est la
problématique de montréal que tout le
monde reconnaît le l'offre en logements
qui n'est pas suffisante l'abordabilité
qui doit être amélioré et conséquemment
si on veut créer des milieux de vie où
il ya aussi des pistes cyclables des
voies piétonnes des parts il n'ya pas
d'autre choix que consultant auteur car
malgré la pandémie la population du
grand montréal continue de croître sous
la pression de l'immigration et des
naissances elle a déjà franchi le cap 4
millions d'habitants et devrait dépasser
les 4,5 millions d'habitants c'est 2036
ya l'étalement urbain qui se poursuit on
peut pas le nier les changements
climatiques vont commander que en plus
du discours y ait des vraies actions ça
veut dire entre autres offrir une
densification heureuse la proposition de
denis coderre a fait débat au printemps
lors de la sortie de son livre retrouvez
montréal nous sommes en désaccord mais
toute tentative de ce truand la vue vers
le mont royal au profit de développement
privées la mairesse plante a fait
adopter une motion par le conseil
municipal afin de souligner l'importance
de préserver l'unicité du paysage
montréalais depuis son avis n'a pas trop
changé il ya plein de façons dansiez et
j'ai envie de vous dire qu'il faut
sortir de l'ancien modèle qui pour -
date 2 il ya 20 ou 30 ans on faisait
dansiez c'est en hauteur en et culot
alors si on veut dansiez différemment ça
veut dire que c'est le nombre de
logements comme à l'intérieur le nombre
de pieds carrés la suggestion de denis
coderre lui a même fait perdre une élue
dans verdun je pense que la vision de
monsieur coderre de construire
en hauteur extrêmes ne fait pas de
montréal une plus grande métropole où
une métropole à niveau supérieur mais le
scepticisme ne vient pas que du milieu
politique dans le fond les grosses des
édifices vont bloquer la vue à quelque
part si je trouve que c'est quand même
déjà très concentré alors on rajouter
encore après je pense que même pour la
vue entre chaque bâtiment sera très
compliqué enfin il y aura plus de
paysages des organismes ont publié une
lettre ouverte en avril pour réitérer
l'importance de la préservation et de la
mise en valeur du mont-royal plus de
villes au monde peuvent se targuer
d'avoir une montagne en arrière scène
qui fait partie son identité pourquoi on
voudrait cacher quelque chose justement
qui fait la renommée de montréal qui
rend montréal est la métropole
attractive j'ai parlé du du mont-royal
de schull évidemment provoquer le débat
malgré ces critiques denis coderre
entend garder le cap sur sa proposition
il inclure dans la plateforme électorale
de son parti ensemble montréal mais il
ne propose pas seulement de densifier le
centre-ville le candidat à la mairie
souhaiterait aussi revoir les hauteurs
permises dans le secteur de l'ancien
hippodrome sur le site du projet
royalmount près des gares du train de
l'est et ailleurs en métropole là où les
limites sont encore plus basses que mont
royal
faut être fédérateur arrêter de voir les
développeurs et les responsables
économiques comme des gens qu'on peut
pas parler plus pointés du doigt on doit
avoir un débat sain sur la densité et
c'est tout simplement ça maintenant il
ya des gens qui peuvent se satisfaire de
peu
le secteur des faubourgs près du pont
jacques-cartier fait partie des secteurs
où un débat fait rage sur les hauteurs
permises et la question a refait surface
en juillet lorsque l'office de
consultation publique a jugé que la tour
de verre du projet immobilier la baie
était trop haute
c'est que l'appétit des promoteurs
immobiliers est énorme au centre ville
une quinzaine de tours de plus de 120
mètres sont en construction cinq d'entre
elles devraient avoisiner les 200 m pour
l'instant il demeure toutefois interdit
de construire au-delà du mont-royal
privilège réservé à l'oratoire
saint-joseph l'exception qui confirme la
règle à 260 mètres au dessus du niveau
de la mer ici jérôme label radio-canada
mourir